President Biden will travel to Poland
next week to mark one year since the
Russia invasion of Ukraine more than 8
million ukrainians in that time have
fled their country that since the War
Began in February of 2022 February 24th
to be exact and as I saw for myself
shortly after the invasion it was the
fastest mass Exodus from a European
country since World War II and the vast
majority of the people coming over the
Border are women teens and younger
children the men stay behind Poland was
the destination for about a million and
a half of those ukrainians seeking
safety and a new MTV documentary don't
leave me behind stories of young
Ukrainian survival follows the lives of
teenage refugees in Poland in this clip
eighteen-year-old Sasha talks about
fleeing her country take a look
[Music]
explain how I go to Poland
how I feel when the record was crashed
I go in car and I sit
city was in fire
in one moment everything can change
and everything can end
the documentary's director Nathaniel
lesra joins us now Nathaniel thank you
very much for being here thanks for
having me you were in Spain when Russia
invades and The Exodus begins yes what
goes through your mind at that moment
um immediately I wanted to focus on the
human side of it I I noticed that there
was a lot of geopolitics a lot of
statistical analysis there wasn't a lot
of discussion of the human impact on
these people fleeing yeah when I was at
the border uh one of the crossings in
Poland it wasn't where the train was
coming over it was where people were
coming over on foot after giving up
because these long convoys of cars talk
about some of the experiences you heard
because I saw only one portion of what
is out there sure
um
bottlenecks people in traffic for weeks
on both sides people Sasha talks in the
film about how and this is a
particularly harrowing experience that I
found uh you know she was in this
bottleneck and there was a skirmish
happening to the left of her in the
woods and on the right of her in the
field and above her in the sky so there
was this position they were in where
they had literally no autonomy no
control over their immediate future and
they as she says in the film have they
have to sit and wait without options
what did you do so beautifully Nat in
this in this documentary is because when
people look at the images you see burned
out buildings Devastation rocks Rubble
you really take us to see the humanity
of the people because these guys are
still kids these young men and women are
still kids who dream of dancing who
dream of playing and what they want more
than anything's to go back home but
they're also afraid they're also still
very afraid and rightfully so yeah the
resilience that you encounter is
extraordinary and resilient yes so you
found us support group Katya was someone
who would set up a support group for
these young people to go and talk yeah
we did it was a it's a foundation in
Poland it's specifically aimed at
Ukrainian young people who have fled
brave people who have seen the absolute
worst one of the dimensions of this is
not only losing your country for an
indeterminate amount of time possibly
forever but it's all women children
younger children teens because the men
not by choice but by circumstance and
law I believe in Ukraine they stay
behind to fight uh talk to us about that
dimension of loss because it's it's not
your country it's your family it's this
role in your life that's hard to Define
but so important yeah it it compounds
the trauma that people are feeling right
it's not only I have to flee I have to
leave this life that I've built it's I
don't know when I'm gonna see my dad
again if I will there are people on
Military Reserve who are on the front
line that Sasha and Dash's fathers are
both Sasha's father is on the front line
in a in in hot zones increasingly hot
zones and Dash's father is on reserve
back in in Ukraine yeah Gail mentioned
those teens and the Teen said it's not a
matter of if it's when we go back to yes
so there is this optimism buried
underneath the fear and despair
um how do they Envision their future
when you were talking with them you know
they talk a lot about how they want to
you know now they've fled they're going
to pursue their European educations
they're going to sort of figure out what
they want in life they've seen so much
already so young but they are going to
go back is it realistic and you know a
couple of them said where uni where
ukrainians we can never be broken is it
realistic because they dream of parks
and Open Spaces of what was
I think I think it's realistic in that
from what I've seen in the ukrainians
that I've met they cannot they have not
and cannot be broken so they're going to
go back and they're going to take what
they've learned and build and build what
did you learn
I learned the value of working with
ukrainians and of listening and passing
the microphone to people who uh need to
take control of their narrative
yeah and they have Nathaniel lesra thank
you very much it's a powerful
documentary don't leave me behind it
airs commercial free this Tuesday on MTV
which like CBS is part of Paramount
global